the Democrat Party has a new strategy to
win elections rather than convince
existing voters on the issues they'll
just create new voters that's why we
have proposals now to grant the right to
vote to felons to children and to
illegal immigrants joining Tammy and me
now is Professor Jason Nichols Jason
what's what's the thinking behind this
why should children vote and why should
people who aren't citizens vote well
with children I would agree you know I
read about the proposal for Washington
DC in particular now this is not a power
grab Washington DC has never been in
play for Republicans 91 percent went for
Hillary Clinton 4 percent went for
Donald Trump so this is not a power grab
by Democrats it's not even in play
nobody know if it's a why even if it
accepting that it's a one-party state
right extending the franchise to minors
is rare is if you say it's unnecessary
that's fine but it's a radical move
nonetheless isn't it I would agree
particularly with 16 but I would say at
17 with parental consent you can enlist
in the military and so I would say
perhaps we should have some sort of
proposal where you can vote at 17 with
parental consent and we would trust you
with the with the national security of
our country then why can't we trust you
to cast a vote
well what about speaking of the national
security what about people who bust into
the country and illegal immigrants
voting is a privilege of citizenship and
allegiance or am I just being mister
squaresville no well I would say you
know if you're affirmed particularly to
a couple of localities in the state of
Maryland particularly College Park
obviously I have an investment in
College Park I think that the first
thing is that this is a local matter
this is not about you know voting for
president or governor or anything like
that it's about fixing potholes it's
about removing snow right and I think
that people who have an investment a lot
of the people whether the
documented or undocumented pay taxes in
those areas pay pay property taxes they
have the right to make some of those
decisions undocumented catchers yeah
tabi go for it yeah look the the city
actually they didn't actually end up
passing that because there was suddenly
a concern that the citizenry didn't
wasn't able to chime in but but your
point Marcus key is that this sets a
tone it sets a precedent and that it's
whether it's like LA and what la in
London do tell you what the left is up
to because there's no pushback but this
is about the franchise about the
importance of being a citizen and and I
think that that's what the American
people are concerned about is where is
this road going and you know you of
course you can't have children voting
with their brain literally is not only
there's a web but that doesn't complete
until you're about twenty-one so these
are efforts to in fact yes in some cases
change the vote or or to enfranchise
more people because you can't persuade
them on the issues the Democrats are
having trouble with that but it's also
to set the precedent that can move
through the rest of the country you use
that quaint phrase the American people
Tammy
Jason bertolt brecht in a very famous
observation after things went badly in
one East German election he said it's
time for the government to elect two new
people this new rainbow coalition all
right because I don't know what it is
people of color gays transgendered
whatever wasn't enough so we're now
importing people to add to the Democrat
voting bloc and we're now extending it
down through high school and grade
school until there's a permanent
majority is that the plan that's the
most apply I think I think that that of
course you are you're being very
hyperbolic there number one well we're
talking about which has been in a
college park again
I think Tammy whisker Tammy is
absolutely correct that you can't change
the Charter unless you have six out of
seven votes they have four so it's kind
of a moot discussion but there are areas
in the in Maryland where undocumented
people who pay taxes who are
participating in those communities are
you know allowed to vote on a
whole and I don't think that there's
anything you know necessarily crazy
there's a stereotactic that says this is
going to come to New York City which
which paragraph of the Constitution has
this amazing a pothole vote in there
Tammy well look politicians have one
idea of what they want and that is to
bring in people or to allow people to
have the vote that they think will vote
for them they conveniently forget about
the fact that we're the sovereign and
look in speaking of New York Governor
Cuomo says he's going to with a stroke
of his pen allow 35,000 felons who are
on parole who have not really completed
their sense because they're still in
parole to be able to vote and he's going
to be able to do that by pardoning them
now already allows felons to vote after
they serve their Tami will get to the
felons next time there's no end to them
thank you for that Tammy thank you Jason